Okay, so here we are on my own Twitter page.
Let's go ahead and see if we can find the Ajax request here.
I'll open up Dev tools.
And I've got the Network tab open.
Let me scroll down really quickly.
And there we go, okay.
So we can see some request happen as I scroll down.
One of those requests is called timeline, and that sounds pretty relevant, so
let's click on it.
Okay, it looks like this includes something along the line of finding tweets,
because I keep seeing tweet here.
All right, that looks relevant.
Let's look at the response.
ha, this looks like HTML to me.
It looks like it's all coming within the property items_html.
So, it looks like the property name is items_html